bonsoir thomas on a vu donc à que ce
dossier évidemment cristallisé les
tensions entre la france et les états
unis a quand même quelques dizaines de
milliards en jeu dans un premier temps
donc demande des comptes à l'australie
puis vient le moment où la diplomatie
française s'interroge sur le rôle et
l'attitude de washington
oui paris s'est montrée passablement
énervé par rapport à l'attitude donc des
américains alors que un haut responsable
de l'administration de la maison blanche
cité par la fp a expliqué qu'il y avait
eu des contacts justement entre des
hauts responsables de l'administration
américaine et leurs homologues français
des contacts justement avant cette
annonce qui a été faite hier de cet
accord entre canberra londres et
washington
une affirmation qui a été démenti il ya
quelques instants par l'ambassade de
france aux états unis le porte parole de
l'ambassade a expliqué à l afp que les
services diplomatiques français ici à
washington avait appris la nouvelle de
cet accord donc mené entre les trois
pays vous avez appris cette nouvelle
dans la presse australienne et
américaine on assiste donc à une sorte
de partie de poker menteur entre les
deux pays alliés et sur le fond le chef
de la diplomatie française s'est lui
montré particulièrement virulent à
l'égard de washington une sortie assez
rare de la part d'un ministre français
des affaires étrangères face au puissant
allié américain écouter jean yves le
drian c'était ce matin
c'est vraiment en bon français un coup
dans le dos nous avions établi avec
l'australie une relation de confiance
cette confiance est trahie et je suis
aujourd'hui en colère avec beaucoup
d'amertume sur cette rupture et vous
n'avez pas plus que ça se fait pas entre
alliés et ça ne se fait pas en plus
quand il y à eut d'abord deux ans de
négociations pour ce contrat ce n'est
pas fini parce que il va vers leur des
clarifications nous avons des contrats
il faut que les autres nous disent
comment ils s'en sortent
nous avons demandé des sommes dues il va
falloir donner des explications nous
avons été sur l'argent à bavois et nous
avons un accord intergouvernemental que
nous avons signés en grande pompe en
2019 avec des engagements précis des
articles de ce texte que le comment ils
s'en sortent il va falloir qu'ils nous
disent donc on n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire est au risque 7e épisode peut
laisser des traces pour l'avenir des
relations entre paris et washington
eh bien le communiqué posté cette nuit
par la diplomatie française témoigne
justement de la colère de paris dans ce
dossier vous avez entendu jean yves le
drian qui attend des clarifications qui
a comparé joe biden à son prédécesseur
donald trump il est aussi intéressant de
lire le tweet qui a été postée hier par
l'ambassadeur de france aux états unis
il est souligné le fait que ce mercredi
marquait le 2 son 40e anniversaire d'une
victoire navale des forces françaises
contre les britanniques à cheaspeake bay
une victoire qui avait conduit à
l'indépendance des etats-unis une
manière pour lui de rappeler les liens
historiques très fort entre les deux
pays des liens historiques qui ont été
quelque peu mise à mal ces dernières
heures alors cet épisode elle n'est pas
le premier exemple des relations parfois
compliquées entre paris et washington on
pourra citer par exemple le refus de la
france de participer à la guerre en irak
en 2003 le dossier alstom ou encore les
révélations sur les écoutes menées par
la nsa sur des dirigeants européens mais
cette fois la différence c'est qu'il y
avait un vent d'optimisme qui soufflait
en europe suite à l'élection de joe
biden on a encore en mémoire les images
justement de la tournée européenne à du
locataire de la maison blanche n'avait
vu beaucoup de signes de rapprochement
de la part de certains dirigeants
occidentaux qui pour certains n'hésitez
pas non plus à glisser quelques
sous-entendus sur leur sur la façon dont
ils disent accueilli avec bienveillance
l'élection en de joe biden en
comparaison est évidemment avec son
prédécesseur donald trump alors tout ça
est un peu remis en question par cet
épisode de ces dernières heures
évidemment america feu c'était bien ça
reste un mantra pour joe biden comme ça
l'a été pour donald trump faudra voir
maintenant comment vont réagir
concrètement la france et l'europe dont
le passé on a vu parfois des réactions
un petit peu timide de la part des pays
européens on verra si sur ce dossier à
l'issue est quelque peu différente s'il
ya une nouvelle stratégie à l'échelle du
vieux continent notamment en matière de
défense
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington